she's great thanks so much to the
organizers for the invitation it's a
great Workshop
we really enjoyed all the talks
this talk is based on joint work with
parikshit Shah who's at Philips research
and it's about
um it's part of a broader project I
guess but I'll focus on one one
interesting component of it in our view
which is to try and explore the
computational properties or
computational aspects of the relative
entropy function so this function is
many beautiful interesting properties
that are used to prove all sorts of
interesting things in information Theory
and statistics and so forth
but this talk is about trying to exploit
The Joint convexity of this function
from a computational perspective this
solves some interesting problems
so the specific problem that I'll focus
on today
is that of signomial optimization
so a signomio is
a function of the following type where I
have sums of exponentials composed with
an affine function
of a variable X and this parametrization
this problem or these functions and the
associated optimization problems are not
convex you can reduce families of NP
heart problems too to examples of
synomial optimization problems a
subclass that some of you may have heard
of is geometric programming this is a
situation where all these coefficients
are positive so you have a positive sum
of convex functions so you end up with
convex optimization problems a term
that's used a lot in that literature
these positive sums of exponentials are
sometimes called polynomials also and so
in geometric programming you minimize a
posynomial the convex function subject
to Upper bound constraints and positive
convex constraints so those problems end
up being tractable to solved but in
general when you have arbitrary signs
pluses and minuses these things get get
more difficult get more challenging
one application
um in fact a broad a broad range of
applications in some in some sense falls
under this sort of General label of
network utility yeah includes all of
polynomial optimization this includes
polynomial optimization over the orthod
right over the non-negative Earth and I
will actually contrast
um at the end you know make some
interesting connections between this and
polynomial optimization when perhaps
sums of squares based methods that have
been explored developed in that
Community how they correspond to things
here sorry minor exponentials so for
instance I could just do a change of
variables where yeah yeah so and they're
not stated this way but if you change
each e to the x side to y i or something
you're solving a polynomial optimization
problem over the Earth
but if you have other constraints then
you can't do that if you what do you
mean other constraints I mean I'm just
considering problems with exponentials
only exponential is the objective no
other types of constraints yeah to be
clear
the alphas are all positive integers
this is
this is a polynomial optimization
problem over the Earth absolutely
okay so one broad sort of class of
applications places where where these
sorts of problems have been solved have
come up
um isn't something called Network
utility management at Princeton has done
a lot of work in this area and it's
broadly about optimally allocating
resources and a network type setting
um to optimize some sort of performance
so one example that I've that I've seen
in this in this context is to allocate
power in some sense across a whole bunch
of users to optimize throughput subject
to constraints that specify bounds and
signal to interference they're not going
to go into the details this isn't my
work this is this is mungs and other and
his collaborators work by them but the
thing that I'd like to highlight is that
when you look at the signal to
interference type constraints in this
context you end up with constraints on
ratios of polynomials and so ratios of
polynomials can be transformed to
signomial optimization problem
solomonial type constraints and so
that's one of the one of the interesting
things that you can do when you allow
your self-synomial type inequalities you
can go from just pausinomial or upper
band constraints and posynomials to more
General types of types of constraints
rational functions of these things and
so forth
and there are a whole bunch of other
settings as well the initial work in
this area was was done by in geometric
programming as well as in signomial
programming
um by a researcher Peterson and as well
as some of his colleagues they had some
applications involving certain
non-linear flow problems and graphs and
so forth there are control problems that
show up in chemical engineering and this
is actually a very prominent class of
class of applications fluidus has a nice
survey article on on those sorts of
problems it shows up in mechanical
engineering problems as well but shows
up a fair bit in many contexts
view of
what I'm interested in a dual view of
fuel if you focus for instance in the
unconstrained case is we're interested
in problems of this type by sort of a
simple transformation
you can also view everything that I'm
doing as trying to understand this
object the convex Hull of a collection
of points where each of these are just
exponentials
um
and so everything that we'll do can be
viewed as trying to understand this
context so although this is a this is a
linear functional this is a convex set
in general this convex set is
interactable the characterize although
this is a convex optimization problem
stated in this parametrization that
doesn't necessarily make sense
okay
and the main idea in this talk is to
develop convex relaxations for signomial
programs based on relative entropy
optimization so for the record the
relative entropy function is defined as
follows and what's very interesting
about it is that it's jointly convex
over both the arguments
and so that joint convexity is something
that will play a key role in in
everything we do
and the
key idea that I'll describe in the next
few slides is a connection between the
relative entropy function and the amgm
inequality which is I'll keep coming
back to it a few times so I figured I'd
actually just write it up on the board
and in the spirit of sum of squares
based relaxations for polynomial
optimization problems we'll be talking
about hierarchies of convex relaxations
based on relative entropy optimization
now for for signomial programming
problems we'll have examples along the
way and at the end in the last few
slides I'll do a sort of talk
qualitatively about uh
but contrast with polynomial
optimization
okay so the basic idea with all these
sorts of things is when you want to
minimize a function in the unconstrained
case you can also talk about maximizing
lower bounds in that function and
effectively based on this reasoning you
get to the idea that you need some
interesting mechanism some framework to
be able to certify non-negativity this
is true for any function of course but
I'm specifically interested now in
certifying non-negativity of signal
means
exponential is a positive and so I'm
okay
but when you start having negative signs
things get interesting the
non-negativity question is interesting
so let's focus on signomials with just
one negative term
so I have a signomium like this
this part will consist of just positive
coefficients and there'll be one term
that could either have a positive or A
negative coefficient and I'm interested
in the global non-negativity of the
signal
this is equivalent to this synomial
being globally non-negative is
equivalent
to the existence of a new such that
these conditions hold
so that relative entropy inequality
status for a fixed C
we fixed beta
the new belongs to the non-negative
orphaned and the system of linear
equations is satisfied
and you can show this via strong Duality
this goes both ways but there's a nice
interpretation of this via the
arithmetic geometric mean inequality
so if you take just the
positive part here
and you apply the amgm inequality with
the weights being
the new Js suitably normalized
you get the very first the very first
line and that's just applying this amgm
inequality if you have a bunch of
non-negative guys that's greater than or
equal to this product where these Delta
I's lie on the simplex
so those are the weights
and this is any a generalized amgm
inequality
so that's the first line the second line
you know everything Remains the Same
except going from the cues to the Alphas
it's stupid and it's just kind of
reminiscent it's reminiscent of the kind
of tricks you do with Jensen's
inequality but there's like but now
there's a product instead of a sum is
there a way to interpret that you have
to log some exp it's gents that's the
convexity of log
summixes
that's that's it but this I mean there
are many ways to write this in this way
sort of sort of most transparent here
um so cues go to the alphas because of
this relationship and that's how we get
the second line there's some more
inequalities to boil this down to this
negative relative entropy and then the
last thing follows by
but listen
so but the key inside the key thing here
really is that the new Js the existence
of those new Js really should be
interpreted as the existence of a set of
Weights that certifies any MGM
inequality
in this case you're wasting you can
always assume there probability measure
on the no so that's that's actually key
these news so once you normalize them
yes it's a probability measure but I'm
searching for news over the non-negative
orthod and that is that is key
so
is this the case that One Direction
is
always true but the other the if and
only if it's only when there is at most
one negative no no the other direction
also follows
um it's a strong Duality argument you
can transform the non-negativity of this
thing
more than one negative
coefficient
oh no this all applies to situations
where there's at most one negative
coefficient and in that case it's if and
only if I'll get to the situation with
more negative coefficients in a second
but in the one negative or at most one
negative coefficient case this goes into
it
so really what you're doing is that
you're searching for weights weights
news that certify any MGM inequality and
thereby certify the global
non-negativity of the signal and it's a
reformulation if you will the different
parameterization
um of early results in GP Duality that
go back to even the late 60s if you
subtract off a term here that it just
depends on C then you can assume that
the Visa are probably distribution if
you subtract off a term that depends
it just depends on the vector C okay
we can talk about this offline so I know
if I should think about something that
says something special is going on here
because it is not opposed the new is not
appropriate distribution
um it turns out actually maybe I should
make talk about this more in detail
offline the early results in GP duality
in fact did assume that new was a
probability distribution they explicitly
worked with things on the Simplex but
that leads to issues that I'll get to in
just two more slides with maybe I can
give it away what's nice about this is
that it's jointly convex new C and beta
if you restrict news to be probability
measures all of the early results of GP
Duality you don't get joint convexity of
the sky and you see in beta and that's
critical for what we want to do later on
and I'll get to that we'll see that in
the next few slides
what this does is to you know what this
does just to reiterate is that we're
searching for weights that certify emgm
inequality
but in all this discussion we've thought
of C beta and these exponents is being
fixed
but now if you just think of these
exponents as being fixed
you can actually think of the set of
globally non-negative signomials with
respect to these exponents
and that said has a nice convex
parameterization based on the result
that I just described
so the set of all C's
that are not negative and betas where
this is true
can be written in this way
this is he nice it's this is certainly a
convex set but the uh The Joint convex
to be a relative entropy we actually
have a nice parametrization for the set
this is a very nice parameterization
the extreme arrays are exactly where
this is equal and so the amgm inequality
satisfied
should put its equality there absolutely
it's an extended formulation for it it
is absolutely an extended formulation of
of the cell uh man I'll actually add a
few words to say about that at the end
all right
so this sort of naturally leads to a
definition so we'll we'll call a
signomial an amgm exponential if it's a
globally non-negative signomial with at
most one negative term and for such
signomials we have an effective
non-negativity certificate via relative
entropy and the spirit that I just
described an example for instance is
this family of signomials for each fixed
Epsilon you can show that the signomial
is globally non-negative
um
the other tool is just described
it was just asked
more General
rules more than one negative term
the natural thing to try to do is to
decompose a general signomial as a sum
of emgm signals because if I'm able to
do this and each term I know can be
efficiently certified as being globally
non-negative
leads to a sufficient condition now not
equivalent unlike in this case but just
a sufficient condition for Global
non-negativity of a signal and so that
leads to the next definition
which is that of a sum of AMG and
exponentials we'll call these things
Sage functions and these are synomules
that can be expressed as a sum of AMG
and exponentials
and a sage function or a signomial being
expressible as a CH function as a
sufficient condition for that signomial
to be globally non-negative
so this is a simple parameterized
example
so A and B parameterize the signomial so
the two positive terms
and two negative terms
the exponents are pi over 4 and 1 minus
pi over four and the same thing swapped
and this is what it looks like the white
cells correspond to this function being
sh function
okay and this is where it's globally
non-negative at least certifiably Sophia
via relative
I'm not thinking of a and b as variables
A and B are fixed coefficients here this
plot tells me all those values of A and
B for which that signomial as a function
of X is globally non-negative so in
those decomposition is one positive term
matched with one negative term or it's
all can be more complicated
sorry could you repeat that question
please I'm decomposing this it turns out
as a sum of two AMG and exponentials
inspect the structure in the sense that
one positive guy is always matched with
one negative card it usually ends up
being that some fraction of these two
positive guys is matched with one and
the remaining piece is matched with the
other one that's exactly is that uh is
that a necessary I mean it's sufficient
for Global non-negativity like here
you've drawn the plot of where it is a
stage function yeah but that's only a
sufficient condition in general it's not
necessary and I'll give examples
architecture where it's not negative in
this picture where it's not negative I
think
it's not this it's a bit bigger than
this so that's all that's
it I guess the question is if if there
is a decomposition like that is it
always a decomposition that only uses
the terms that are already there or
sometimes you add new games so the way
we'll construct this is just by using
exponentials that are already there and
I'll get to that I mean but it's not a
necessary condition sometimes could be a
more complicated decomposition what do
you mean by more complicated
decomposition it doesn't use terms that
are already there
what do you mean by terms that are
already there I'm a bit unclear sorry
so I could add more exponentials add and
subtract yeah yeah you could in general
do that and that in general can be
helpful
and what I'll described we'll just stick
the sage functions with respect to just
a thick set of exponentials I.E the
exponentials that appear in our signal
but in general you could add
exponentials with zero coefficients and
um you can actually do a bit better and
I don't have examples of that here but
I'm happy to talk about that
okay so formally actually relating very
much to the point that is brought up
let's fix now a set of exponents
the set of sage functions with respect
to these exponents is a convex column
and that set is described as follows
it's all functions
written in this in this way
notice that the number of terms here is
exactly equal to the number of
exponentials and each fi is going to be
an amgm exponential where the I
coefficient is allowed to possibly be
negative
to each F5 globally non-negative
and it also is written in terms of those
exponentials
and with the exception of the ith
coefficient here everything else must be
positive
okay so this answers your question where
at least when we Define Sage functions
we do it with respect to a set of
exponentials
and each of these FIS can now be
certified to be globally non-negative in
an effective way via VIA relative
entropy
now if checking Sage decomposability
with respect to a set of exponents is a
relative entropy program and the
coefficients of your signomial
this is something that's convex
efficiently solved and it leads to a
natural relaxation in natural convex
lower Bound for unconstrained SPS it's
very much in the spirit of what I
described a few slides ago very much in
the spirit of sum of squares based lower
bounds for polynomial optimization so I
can fix a set of exponents f of x is a
signomial with respect to these
exponents and I'm going to maximize the
lower bound gamma subject to f x minus
gamma being sh function with respect to
those exponents
and this does
interesting things
so this is actually um so even for you
know in the special case where we have
non-negative integer coefficients and we
get polynomials yeah and we can talk
about the proof system of time I will
very much talk yeah yeah so you're
defining a proof system I'm defining a
proof system
uh so for example again this is
something I wanted to talk about it you
can you can combine the two certainly
some of squares gives more concise
proofs for non-negativity of certain
polynomials that Sage does not but there
are equally examples where this will
give a more concise proof than some
squares or you know the degree bounds of
the proof system for checking you know
polynomials non-negative you have to go
to rational functions sometimes so I
guess I'm asking you know do you
um
you can show that this I mean the sage
methodology I'll actually formally
describe a hierarchy I've just described
a basic relaxation I'll describe a
hierarchy that will in fact be complete
for for polynomial
alternative but yeah we we will actually
show this but again all phrased on the
language of SPS because that's really
that's really what I'm interested in but
so this is
um consists of six terms and three
variables so the first three terms are
what we fixed the last three terms are
what we chose randomly I'll undescribe
that construction in the next slide
um but this is you know not obviously
something that you can solve using
geometric programming certainly Trying
to minimize this the signal meal because
there are two negative terms there
so this is not a GP we minimize this
produce a lower bound using sage and we
get that bound and there is a wave that
I'll describe in the next few slides
by which we obtain a point that
certifies the upper bound
but this the same the same value is also
an upper path
not something that I'll get to
in a second so this construction more
generally was done as follows we fixed
the first three terms the last three
terms were chosen in the following way
the coefficients of zero mean gaussians
and the exponents are uniform in this
range and the reason we chose the
exponents to be in this range 0 through
3 and if you look at the first three
exponents they're much larger than than
that range
is to somehow hopefully get synomials
that are actually bounded below if you
don't have signomials that are bounded
below and you try they have a framework
to produce lower bounds and you get
Negative Infinity you actually have no
idea if your framework is somehow
failing or if the signomial itself is
unbounded below so this was an attempt
um to produce a family of signomials
that are hopefully bounded for them and
in this in this random family we applied
this technique and the sage relaxation
ends up being tight and 60 plus percent
cases out of 80 80 random drives again I
want to emphasize oops that these stars
are gaussians so they can be positive
negative
um and so
these certainly are not GPS and the what
we had in the previous slide was an
example of this
it obviously fails in some cases and so
one can now
um before I talk about the hierarchy
I'll need to define a quantity this is
obtained by taking all bounded
integer combinations of the exponents
where the weights sum up to at most p
and based on this based on this
definition
we can we we have the following um
following title lower bound we maximize
gamma subject to a positive function
times f of x minus gamma being Sage
this guy is positive because it's just a
sum of exponentials
um the exponents here times the
exponents here give rise the things that
consist of p plus one possible
combinations of all the exponents and
that's why we have this exponent set
here
and this is a tight and sufficient
condition for Global non-negativity than
what I had a few slides ago previously
we just had that f of x minus gamma is
Sage with respect to E1
and now we have this thing raised to the
power of P has to be sage and e p plus
one
you can show that this again this is a
lower Bound in the optimal value because
this is a sufficient condition for
non-negativity you can show that this is
non-decreasing with respect to p
and we have the following completeness
uh result the one thing I'll mention
before I actually describe the result is
that this should be reminiscent if you
look at the polynomial world or polio
Resnick type that result where you have
uniform denominators and so forth
the theorem is as follows the sequence
of lower bounds
advancing value provided these
conditions are satisfied by the
exponents irrational
the number of exponents is bigger than
the dimension of the problem the
dimension of the variable X
this is not a very stringent condition
if this is not satisfied you can always
reduce the dimension of your problem
the second condition is that the
exponents the first n of the exponents
are linearly independent again not
difficult you can you know just group
the first n of them or group the largest
linearly independent set into the first
n and that's okay
you can always add the zero exponent
this essentially corresponds to a
constant term
the last condition is what's interesting
I'll talk about why we needed a few
slides later
but what you need is that the remaining
exponents outside of the first and then
the zero are contained in the convex
Hull of the first n plus one
okay
so this is sort of a simple picture in
two Dimensions if you have a signomial
optimization problem involving two
variables the first two are these ones
then you add zero and all the other
exponents ought to belong in that
context so
there's a precise reason why we need
this
so the Dual Viewpoint as promised as I
mentioned right at the beginning
we can reformulate an unconstrained SP
the minimization of something of that
type
into the minimization of a linear
functional subject to this convex set
and everything that I've talked about
all these relaxations both the basic one
as well as the hierarchy can be viewed
as producing tractable convex outer
approximations to this set
yeah
so if you have a convex outer
approximation of the set it stands to
reason that when you minimize C
transpose V you will get a lower bound
so that's a different way of seeing that
everything that I talked about produces
a lower band what was emotional
convergence for the
notion of convergence it converges From
Below it's
non-decreasing so
SP increases
it's the usual kind of completeness
result
bound on P in terms of N I wish we could
do that but in general I mean those are
hard problems even in the polynomial
World
um
I'll have a bit to say about it then at
the end but but no even for very simple
cases and polynomial optimization uh the
bounds that do exist tend to be
pessimistic
these things and these sorts of
relaxations end up doing far better than
predicted frequently so effective bounds
in the hierarchy that actually reflect
problem difficulty I think I think it's
an interesting hard question
okay so the Duel of the very basic Sage
relaxation can be viewed as follows you
minimize the linear function subject to
this constraint set
this is what the basic stage relaxation
does and as I mentioned that constraint
set is an outer convex approximation to
this set
and it's a constraint set specified in
terms of relative entropies all your
exponents and so forth
so this is the Dual of that first level
of that Sage hierarchy
So based on this
it's now easy to see how you can
potentially verify if the solution that
you found
using this method is actually the
optimal solution of the original problem
or is a global minimizer of the original
problem right you solve this you get a v
and if that V Lies in this set
you're done
and let's exactly described on the slide
you get an optimal V after solving this
relaxed problem you take logarithms
because of this exponential this
collection of exponentials and you ask
that it satisfies an over determined
system of linear equations
and if it does satisfy this then you've
exactly solved the original problem and
this is very much in Spirit by the way
if you've seen the literature and STP
relaxations for polynomials if you solve
the basic uh on you know the basic SOS
if you saw the STP corresponding to the
basic SOS relaxation and your solution
is rank one somehow you've actually
solved the original problem this is very
much an analog of that except that now
you have that this point belongs to this
curve or the surface of exponentials and
if you have some if you have that
property hold you've actually solved the
original problem
moving to constrained SPS I mean that
can be harder more interesting stories
with the unconstrained case in general
with all this with all this stuff moving
to the constrained case you have a
collection of signomial specifying
constraints now that's the same sort of
story you can reformulate this via
restricted non-negativity a maximize
gamma subject to f x minus gamma being
non-negative on the constraint set
and as before we'll give sufficient
conditions for restricted non-negativity
and that will give us a family of lower
bands so for instance you can maximize
gamma subject to f x minus gamma
minus this guy being Sage
this is just sort of the the and if you
wanted to prove a weak Duality type
argument if you wanted to compute The
lagrangian Duel of your original GP you
would do exactly this and ask that this
thing be globally non-negative you're
replacing that with sage
pretty standard
but even this does some interesting
things if you have the subjective
function again two negative terms it's
an example from before and you have the
following constraints set
you get something that is in fact tight
what's interesting here I mean just a
point and note not necessarily
interesting is that this constraint set
is convex
the objective function though does
consist of negative signs so this is
again not a GP
going to sort of a more General
constraint set
um
not necessarily convex because it has
lots of negative signs negative and
positives mixed
well you can see that this is
this was generated in the same sort of
random fashion that the objective was
generated and based on the description a
few slides ago and in fact in the
constrained case we struggle to find
examples at least in this random
Ensemble one objective one constraints
generated in the random way that I
described a few slides earlier we
struggle to find examples with this very
basic relaxation failed in your planting
a very nice certificate that the
function is is
the this system this is not a nice cert
I mean this is a sufficient condition
I mean I can eat I can prove to you I
don't have to be at stage zero one that
this thing is going to be uh I mean the
point is right you're you're making the
exponents of the positive Parts very big
and the exponents in the negative Parts
smaller and then in your your
constraints but that does not make the
problem right if I threw this into a GP
solver
there's no way you could actually
produce a lower bat and by the way I'm
not asking you to certify the
non-negativity of this I'm asking you to
find a you know minimize this function
or minimize this function subject to
these constraints and we have no
methodology to actually do this if we
have multiple it may look easy
but that doesn't mean that it is sort of
trivial or we have a direct methodology
today you make James happy can you can
you show that the passion is is
indefinite here because that's another
thing in this case yes we actually we
did something different I think we found
a line on which this was not convex so
that's
it yeah
these are not trivial or easy problems
it's not Congress
this is not convex you can actually find
we've developed a convex relaxation
framework for this that turns out to be
tight in these cases but this objective
function is not convex you can actually
find a line segment convex on lines just
the right geometry absolutely convexity
of a function is equivalent at being
convex and all right but I mean like
instead like some sort of tracing out a
you know X but if I'm being asked to
prove that this is not convex if I can
show that it's you know restricted to
some line it's not convex that's good
enough right but in general yeah there
may be a different geometry to these
things
the geodesics are not necessarily but
this I mean I don't know that we need to
get that complicated I'm just answering
a very simple question which is this
function we have a line where we know
that uh the self-convex restricted to
that line so it's not a convex
yeah so I mean it's just answering a
very simple question that was raised but
then
okay so one can again talk about a
hierarchy of relaxations in the in the
constrained case we have the same sort
of bounded linear combinations a bounded
integer combinations of exponents as
before we have products
of our constraints
um and these will specify redundant
constraints as a sort of standard and
optimization
and you maximize again a lower bound
subject to adding in all these redundant
constraints
and asking that these redundant
inequalities also hold
we use Sage multipliers they're usager
I'm not going into the details of this
because this is
um
very similar to What's Done in
polynomial optimization where you
replace these LaGrange multipliers in
the basic weak Duality thing that I
mentioned before by Sage functions you
replace this by sh function and you can
build a hierarchy based on based on this
idea this is a tighter sufficient
condition for constrained non-negativity
because you've added in all these
redundant constraints
and as before you can show that the
sequence of lower bounds produced by
this hierarchy also converges to the
optimal value provided essentially the
following constraint the following
condition hole that the constraint set
is compact
so the constraint case we need this this
compactness assumption
proof idea and
this is the following I mean we need the
following two Notions from from the
algebraic geometry literature that of a
pre-prime and that of a module over
pre-prime the set of signomials with
positive coefficients
polynomials as I mentioned before
forms a pre-prime because it's closed
under additional multiplication
the set of sage functions forms a module
over this pre-prime because multiplying
a sage function by a polynomial
still gives me a sage function and so
this forms a module over that pre-prime
and sort of within this within this
framework we appeal to a positive Stalin
sounds that really talks about
non-negativity certificates of
um for positive polynomials over modules
and the unconstrained case that convex
Hull assumption that I had really ties
in closely to certain archimedianity
conditions is a very technical thing
that shows up in appealing to these
positive selling such results
that's really the manifestation of it in
the unconstrained case and the
constrained case the compactness
assumption is what allows us to satisfy
this archimedianity assumption and these
positive Stones results that's really
what shows up uh and a lot of these
representation theorems in real
algebraic geometry the sort of
archimedianity condition that needs to
be satisfied and that's the reason for
those two assumptions and the
constraints are on constraint cases
okay so there are some nice interesting
properties of these relaxations that are
actually not revealed by these
completeness results these completed
results just basically say eventually
you converge you get to the right thing
after solving something very large but
there are other very interesting
properties that uh
that are not necessarily revealed by
that theorem the first is by sort of
construction GPS are exactly solved at
the first levels of these hierarchies
simple basic point to be made but it is
an important one and that anytime you
develop a framework you'd hope that easy
problems continue to remain easy and
that's certainly the case here but the
first level also solves problems that go
beyond GP so this was an example that we
were able to minimize but you know more
than zero negative signs there are two
negative signs there so we do end up
solving problems being on GPS
recipes also have signomial optimization
problems also have a nice and variant
property so if you take all the
exponents in your problem both in the
objective and in the constraints
and apply a non-singular linear
transformation simultaneously to all of
them the underlying SP remains unchanged
so the optimal value remains unchanged
non-negativity properties and so forth
remain unchanged and you'd like this to
also be a feature of any methodology you
develop recipes and it's certainly the
case that Sage decompositions
sort of respect us invariance
a third sort of interesting property is
the robustness of the sage relaxation to
perturbing the exponents so if you take
this unconstrained SP the sun
constrained synomial following from the
examples before that sort of just
written in a different way six terms
we were tight
I'm going to leave the coefficients
unchanged but I'm going to perturb the
exponents
so it's perturbed all the exponents
slightly
and we get a closed signomial in some
sense
and we continue to sort of you know
remain tight produce a solution that's
close by produce an optimal value that's
close by and so forth so this sort of
robustness is also something that you'd
like if
of any framework you develop recipes and
this is one point one cents in which SP
is a very different in comparison to
polynomial optimization problems because
you'd like robustness with respect to
the exponents too
if I have a small integer exponent 2 for
example and I change two to two million
divided by one million and one
it's very very close to two but if I
think of it as a polynomial problem
things sort of blow up I mean that's
just not the right sense in what you
want to think about SPS especially if
you care about robustness with respect
to the exponents
we have a theorem that describes why
ysps are actually robust I won't go into
the details of this the main thing that
I want to point out is something
qualitative the reason for all these
properties in variance under the
application of a non-singular
transformation all the exponents
robustness with respect to perturbations
of the exponents and so forth all really
can be seen when you go back to the
basic certificate that we employed right
in the beginning for signomials with
just one with at most one negative term
and the exponents if you think about it
in the original signomial appear
as just linear equations
and so if you put up these of the
original linear equations will somehow
not degenerate in some sense
you will still get a nearby set of
linear nearby I find space and so things
are likely to be okay
and that's really the reason why we have
robustness with respect to perturbing
the exponents we have invariance with
respect to simultaneous non-singular
transformation applied to both sides it
really follows from from that
relationship and that's really why why
all these nice properties actually hold
okay
so let's do some contrast for polynomial
optimization topic that's actually
received a lot more attention uh
so we have STP relaxations for
polynomial optimization problems based
on some squares decompositions there is
sort of a natural correspondence in that
world you use sums of squares
decompositions to certify non-negativity
here we talk about Sage signomials there
are some squares decompositions lead
naturally to sdps here these guys lead
naturally to relative entropy
relaxations
so what are the comparative advantages
of these Frameworks when is one may be
better than the other and so forth right
so here is an example of a signomio
that is not Sage
it's a signomial with six terms it's
globally non-negative because I can
write it as a perfect square
so it's evidently not negative
well this signomial is not sage and the
way we came up with it is based on some
connection to H matrices that I can talk
about later
so clearly even even if you restrict
yourself to The Limited family of
polynomial optimization problems or
synomial problems where the exponents of
small positive integers
SOS is doing something that's different
from sage and maybe Sage is doing
something that's a bit different from
SOS
so what's really going on the answer is
I mean I don't completely know but a few
thoughts
so if you have SPS with the rational
exponents
in principle these can be transformed to
polynomial optimization problems over
the Earth and
so if you think about just such
signomial programs when a sum of squares
useful for recipes if you can transform
the original SP to a polynomial
optimization problem hopefully with low
lick retails right that's hopefully when
you expect all that literature to be
very very useful it may still I think be
interesting to study combinations of
sage and sum of squares because for
example the modskin polynomial
viewed suitably as a sage function
but it's not a sum of squares at least
not directly a sum of squares although
you can certify it's not negativity with
just one level up in the hierarchy
when my sage decompositions be useful if
your SP has exponents with large
denominators so clearing denominators
potentially leads to very very large
degree polynomials in the resulting
polynomial optimization problem
if you have SPS even with rational
exponents while they may be
transformable the polynomial
optimization problems in principle
the CH methodology is still useful
because you care about different things
you care about robustness with respect
to different kinds of perturbations and
so forth so and what the sorry yeah
so was there an algorithm for stadium
for signomial programming you mean not I
mean there were tons of methods in the
optimization literature based on branch
and bound and so forth sorry with your
work yeah is there one or there is one
that that's
the result was that we have a hierarchy
of relative entropy
I mean just GP GPS
I know the complexities and to the heart
what is the complexity and what's the
complexity of a certain level in the
hierarchy
what do you
know the power P indexes
the level in the hierarchy for instance
in the unconstrained case you have p and
Q that index is a power of the hierarchy
maybe the constraint case is simpler to
look at
this is the constraint case I'm sorry
the unconstrained case it's important
p is the power here
I think the question is what do you use
in order to solve this what do we use to
solve this or I mean this is a convex
optimization problem and we just use
sort of a basic interior Point method to
solve this
it will be on the order of L to the P
yeah
L is the number of exponents
L to the P the number of exponents in
your SP no I didn't mean this one right
basically the number of exponents in
your signomial
so if you count the dimension it will be
uh
like n to the P or yeah L to the P yes
yeah yeah and that's that's roughly what
it ends up exactly and again there
you'll have q as well sure
just log of one reps
there's no Epsilon here
optimization
this is an optimization problem I've
talked about this optimal value he said
Jeep is asking what is the algorithm for
solving geometric program right yeah you
fix an Epsilon and you were able to
solve for that accuracy
interior point and it's log of one over
yeah oh idea and the airplane works for
this this is better than log one over
Epsilon is you get quadratic converts
right you use the Primal dual on that
they do yes we used only a primal only
method and so forth
yeah yeah but uh yeah I mean so this is
a convex program with a nice barrier
function and so forth so yeah that is
the algorithm yeah
I mean I guess I swept all that under
the rug when I said that the relative
entropy function is jointly convex
and
oh that's enough to give everything not
in general no because convexity may just
because the functions context doesn't
mean it's extractable but this is a nice
convex function in some sense they're
really nice algorithms for geometric
programming okay really I mean a GP is
I don't know some might dispute this but
GP is roughly on the same order of
complexity as an LP
in some sense of you know the right size
so this is also the intuition why I use
the relative entropy of order one in
this relaxation I use the relative
entropy of order one
at the level one yeah yeah
what was into I'm sorry I don't follow
the question like this whole family is
of relative entropy so I just wanted to
kind of understand why this one
especially like why by kind of the
standard relative entropy which is also
called order one is kind of special in
the city why it's kind of special well
is this because of the exponential just
because it's constructible then or
I'm still not sure if all the questions
because
um these larger levels of the hierarchy
still involves the relative entropy
function but just computed over a larger
number of variables so I don't know when
you
conjugate oh there's other relative and
that's the question okay yes no this was
the relative entropy that's not that
naturally parameterizes an amgm
inequality and that's the reason we used
it yeah I mean there are other I don't
know the classical case of there are
other relative entropies perhaps based
on other entropies
no this is not the quantum boiler yeah
yeah
um
where did I stop yes
small proofs here so what about you know
examples where you sort of need very
high degree
through you know uh some system
polynomial is not feasible do some of
those examples and translate coming up
lower right here complexity let's see
the next one last example sorry uh so I
mean I'm going to stated more in terms
of sets so this so consider the
following set where A and B are
coefficients of this univariate
polynomial
and I want all possible A's and B's
two-dimensional set convex set where
this univariate polynomial is globally
non-negative
it's STP representable is a projection
of a slice of the PSD convex and
algebraic and so forth as far as I know
the size of any STP I was able to write
down grows with d
so as I increase this DB is a positive
integer here the size of any STP
description of this
seems to grow a d
my sdb description means exact exact sdp
representation of the set
by that I mean a projection onto two
dimensions of a larger sdp cone slice
with an affine space it exists it exists
based on sum of squares yeah that's an
existence proof
this is just a univariate polynomial
very very simple
but there's no proof though that the
size of the sdp grows there's no proof
yes I don't have a proof but I think
it's ought to be possible because the
boundary of this
this
yeah because
if you take this convex set the boundary
ends up having very very large degree
um but there is a very nice description
of exactly that set using relative
entropy
so all A's and B's that satisfy this
condition so the existence of a new
such that this relative entropy
inequality holds where A and B show up
and that linear equation holds
exactly characterizes this thing so we
have a convex semi-algebraic set
something that semi-deferal
representable contrived of course but
still I think it makes a point that you
have a lift and project method where the
lift involves
fundamentally something that's
non-algebraic
when you project it down you get
something that is semi-algebraic
but the sort of non-algebraic structure
upstairs leads to a more much more
efficient description
that does not grow in size but d
uh of the original sin
which is that that equation you said D
minus one times mu 1 equals new two yep
so the only
the only flexibility is the length of
the vector I guess
you want a new one
this is new is in two-dimensional space
so the new one is the first coordinate
U2 is the second coordinate nothing else
will be like AMG and proof underneath it
is sort of Highly unbalanced because the
parts you know yes that's exactly it and
that's the last slide of the talk sorry
uh so if you want to prove the amgm
inequality with fixed rational weights
you can give a sum of squares proof of
the AMG of inequality
but depending on the kind of rational
weights you have that proof can be very
very long
but relative entropy searches over these
weights to certify non-negativity via
amgf and in some situations I think this
this idea could be much more powerful
even for polynomial problems
very much but it's a low degree example
of it but it's also an illustration yeah
right so for example compared let's say
the source Quest proof of something like
Hitler's inequality and the AMG impm
proof perhaps that's very much that's a
good example exactly exactly that's
exactly yeah that's very much an example
of this so to summarize I don't think
I'll say much more maybe the one point I
should mention is that um
relative entropy optimization in the
sense that we really exploit The Joint
convexity of relative entropy with
respect to both arguments ends up being
useful in a bunch of other settings I'm
happy to talk about these offline
um yeah thank you
well
well uh this time we'll do another very
quickly but instead of a sum of
exponentials if you had a trace of an
exponential of some Matrix
very interesting question yeah uh
anything you can do with that we have
thought about this
um
I can talk a bit offline you can certify
lower bounds for various you know for
very very special problems of that type
using Quantum relative entropy
but it's still something I don't
understand completely uh I can tell you
what I know but yeah
questions comments Sanji so uh
uh I guess I don't know so much anything
about GP but uh it seems somehow just
the way the phrasing seems it seems
should be highly non-robot numerically
but it is robust everything it is
you went very fast over the robustness
theorem so I could it was very wordy
um
this is yeah that's the reason but this
is this is
a notion of robustness robustness in the
sage context
programming stability yeah the stability
of just GPS uh with respect it's all
it's generally well understood and it's
and these are statements
you know that you're ridiculous
yeah that's one prime example it is I
mean it is well conditioned if you will
CS people don't often know that
literature just for you yeah
certainly talk more about that yeah
we can all read that book tomorrow
one more question could you show some
examples where like your uh hierarchy is
so do you understand those or I mean not
I mean other than giving sort of a
self-referential things those are things
that are written as age functions or
whatever I no not really
the parameter is randomly is Randomness
anything related to I don't think so I
think in that case it was not just
Randomness but the specific construction
sum of the exponentials were large and
fixed the others were small and random
that played a role certainly
um
yeah I wish I could say more to be
something we're interested in but
did I miss him
the absolute last one
then F0 that can never happen
at least if you solve it to you know
which is arbitrary he's talking about
the first level of the hierarchy doing
worse than this second doing better than
the second level of the hierarchy
F1 better or worse
I thought the if you make more levels
you get a yes yes yes that is true did
you show any numerical examples not of
that I have a backup
this is an example where and you know
that eventually it becomes time for me
yes and eventually it becomes that this
is a simple this is one of the backup
slides a simple example of
this doesn't mean anything those are
just numbers but at least for your
random examples how high you have to go
to get well like I said a decent that
Ensemble 60 of them were tied to the
very first level yeah um this was one
example that was not tight we tried the
second level I don't think this is tight
either
um but
perhaps yeah
because if we have positive questions
you can catch then get probably the
recipe
right
now